1959 voici coccinelle vedette des
cabarets parisiens
la première femme transgenre à
apparaître à la télé elle racontait sa
notoriété plus tard en 1996 j'ai été
émis en haut de l'échelle d'un seul coup
non pas par des managers non pas par des
publicités c'est le public qui m'a fait
comme ça mais en dehors du monde du
spectacle
la transidentité à la télé a un goût de
scandale une affaire dans les années 70
terni l'image des transgenres celle des
travestis de marseille deux jeunes
garçons qui ont recours à des hormones
et se prostitue
au delà de ce scandale la télé donne la
parole à des transgenres loin des
clichés exposés dans la presse écrite
c'est sur le plateau de france 3
marseille en 1976 on est transsexuel ce
n'est pas opérée pour devenir
transsexuels se fait opérer pour
atteindre notre équilibre parfait
obtenir l'identité civile féminine et
pourvoir pour pouvoir vivre une vie
normale une vie normale parce que
moralement nous sommes femmes
physiquement pas encore tout à fait à la
télévision dans les années 70 ce sont
souvent des femmes transgenres qui
s'expriment opérer ou non
moi même je me considérais comme ce que
j'étais c'est à dire comme une femme
ayant un corps qu'il ne lui appartenait
pas la télévision se fait aussi l'écho
des avancées législatives des
transgenres la possibilité de changer
d'état civil la fin des discriminations
en tous genres en france les
transsexuels ont désormais une existence
légale la cour de cassation a en effet
déclaré au nom du respect dû à la vie
privée que les transsexuels avait droit
à la modification de la mention de leur
sexe sur les actes d'état civil
la france a pris une décision qualifiée
d' historique par les associations
nous sommes en effet le premier pays au
monde à ne plus considérer la
transexualité comme une maladie mentale
c
dernières années un autre phénomène
pourtant ancien et relayer les
agressions transphobes celle de julia
est devenu un symbole insulté ébouriffés
et frappé place de la république à paris
en 2019
c'est pas juste les agressions physiques
c'est également voilà beaucoup
difficultés pour trouver un emploi
malheureusement pour le logement
également il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui sont discriminés même si la
transidentité intéresse la télé depuis
les années 50
aujourd'hui les transgenres est peu
représenté dans les sphères de
visibilité que ce soit en politique ou
dans les médias
[Musique]